this is a Fox News Alert
moments ago authorities in Chicago have
just released nearly 70 hours of video
related to the alleged racial and
homophobic attack against actor justice
Millette the immense collection of
evidence includes police reports videos
photos one piece of video shows two
officers arriving at smollett's home
you're looking at that here the night of
the alleged incident where he still has
that makeshift noose around his neck
small debt was charged with 16 counts of
alleging he'd lied to police when
reporting he had been a victim of a
racist anti-gay attack in January police
contend the black and openly gay actor
staged the attack because he was unhappy
with his salary and wanted pool is
publicity but prosecutors you'll
remember dropped the charges on March
26th without smile at admitting guilt
last week a judge called for a special
counsel to investigate the Cook County
prosecutors actions in the case this
video is extensive we're still going
through it
we wanted to bring that to you from
Chicago police